so this is the Toshiba mini and B 205
it's a pretty cool netbook it's $400 and
it's got the new Intel and 280 processor
which is one point six six gigahertz but
the main improvement is that it offers
smoother video playback so the things
that I like about this netbook are it
has a really nice big trackpad compared
to other netbooks we've tested it's nice
and wide to make mousing around a lot
easier and a lot less cramp even have an
experience but on the negative side I
really really didn't like the keyboard
there's way too many keys in the bottom
row and I kept I don't know why there's
this tailed key on the bottom here but
just I kept hitting that instead of the
Alt key I'm pretty good type or two
overall just made plenty of mistakes
typing and that can get pretty annoying
over time but something that's really
really nice about this netbook is it has
really long battery life and if you can
see in the back and actually they make
it pretty obvious like in terms of
physical appearance that you get about
six hours of battery life from our
testing we just played a video
continuously and and that that's really
awesome it's it's probably the longest
battery that we've seen in a netbook and
in the past we've had something that's
run for five hours and another thing
that this netbook has that's sort of a
special feature is that if you move
around the hard drive to a little bit or
if you nudge it and it shakes it it
automatically moves the hard drive
sensor head to a safe area to protect
your data from any damage so one major
piece of advice is do not get the pink
one like I'm not just it's not just a
color preference but actually the pink
is so flamboyant that when vibrant that
it tricks your eyes into thinking that
the white windows are kind of purplish
on the screen and there's not really
much you can do about that that just how
your eyes work you know so there are
four other colors there's a brown black
white and I believe a dark blue and you
just go with one of those just yeah pink
pink she should be out of the picture so
for $400 I think this is pretty good
value it's got really nice battery life
really roomy trackpad but just keep in
mind
that this keyboard is kind of awkward
kind of strange it's not like any other
keyboard that you've probably used and
if you can get used to that sure good
deal but you know I can so good luck